There's so many different kinds of life
on earth, but all living things are
related to each other. Scientists
divide all living things into one of
two groups: eukaryotes and prokaryotes.
At a very basic level, eukaryotes have
cells with many specialized
compartments inside of them that we
call organelles. Organelles give them
capabilities that prokaryotes do not
have.
Imagine every species on earth as the
tip of a huge tree's branching roots.
People and dogs are very different, but
if we follow the roots back into the
past, we find a common starting point,
or a common ancestor, that wasn't a dog
or a human, but it was still a mammal.
In the same way, mammals and insects
are very different, but they are joined
together as part of the animal kingdom.
If we go further back in time, and I
mean way, way back, back before our
ancestors split from the ancestors of
mushrooms or trees, back when the world
consisted of only single celled
organisms. About two or three billion
years ago, a new form of life emerged
that paved the way for all forms of
life that you can see around you, and
many forms of life that you can't see.
This was the birth of eukaryotes.
Scientists think that one day a small
cell that was good at making energy was
devoured by a larger cell. Instead of
destroying the little energy maker, by
some stroke of luck, both cells started
working together. The combination of
the small cell's increased energy
production and the larger cell's
protective outer layer allowed both
cells to flourish, and overtime their
descendants evolved organelles with
very specialized functions that almost
all eukaryotes share today. Mushroom,
human and Redwood cells all share a
nucleus that stores their DNA,
lysosomes that break down waste, and
mitochondria which produce energy.
Prokaryotes, like E. coli, have none of
these specialized compartments. The
development of organelles allowed cells
to accomplish newer and different
challenges, like working together to
build complex, multicellular organisms,
such as animals, plants and fungi. If
it hadn't been for that first
partnership between two tiny single
celled organisms, we certainly wouldn't
be here, and life today would be much
more microscopic than it is.